[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec une actualité fournie que nous
allons commenter évidemment la banque de
bernard tapie la condamnation d'un
ancien président de la république la
montée de d'eric zemmour dans les
sondages qui placent peut-être l'extrême
droite si on la joute à marine le pen à
31 % la capacité de la droite à se
trouver un candidat et le tout sur un un
paysage français qui semblent divisés en
deux parties d'un côté la france urbaine
de l'autre côté la france périphérique
donc des sujets passionnants et pour en
parler deux étudiants salomé traits du
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes étudiant la
science po saint germain
nelson gaspa bonjour bonjour vous êtes à
l'uv est-ce que vous êtes dirigé l'umih
un rsa du vs cul et puis deux engagés
politique pire luce pour jour vous êtes
le responsable de l ère obama dans les
yvelines et quentin des mers bonjour
vous êtes conseiller municipal à lui en
cours vous êtes membre du pcf et jean
plus proche des je suis aussi étudiant
et je suis étudiant absolument oui et ça
fait trois étudiants c'est très bien
alors quand il ya des idiots fin prof
donc une version couronne est là mais
pas il sera très indulgent avec vous un
il ay va pas ou note écrit bonjour
vincent bouge un peu plus le jeu
fondateur des surligneurs vous êtes vous
êtes ainsi notre journaliste et vous
allez-vous publié avec les surligneurs
d'ailleurs un livre sur la religion et
la politique dont nous parlerons la
semaine prochaine on va consacrer une
émission à ce sujet la semaine prochaine
et puis on cerne lajoinie bonjour
bonjour vous êtes et dieter zetsche le
président et fondateur d excellentes
éditions la joie ni consacrer le plus
souvent au polar mais pas quand c'est
essentiellement tout la présence ennemie
[Musique]
alors on va commencer par ba cette
actualité la mort de bernard tapie j'ai
commencé peut-être parler les plus
jeunes d'entre vous si je peux dire ça
vous évoque quoi bernard tapie c'est un
outil qui vous étaient familiers
salomé oui c'est un nom qui mettait
assez familier mais aussi parce que je
les ai vus dans le cadre de sciences po
on a étudié un peu les la privatisation
des fonctions régaliennes et c'est vrai
qu'on a pas mal pencher sur l' affaire
tapie donc j'en ai vu un peu par ce
biais là sur la sphère tu habites dans
le compte ou le crédit lyonnais
notamment oui c'est ça d'accord d'accord
alors évidemment bernard tapie ça
m'évoque quelque chose alors il faut
savoir que quand je prends une personne
pour exemple je garde ce qui a de
positif pour le prendre en exemple et
que je retire le reste d'accord ce que
je retiendrai de positif du moins de
bernard tapie au delà de tout le négatif
c'est la diversité des engagements il a
été artiste il a été politique
d'ailleurs politique on a souvent essayé
de lui mettre un plafond de verre sport
il a été entrepreneur sous plusieurs
casquettes il a toujours été passionné
par ce qu'il faisait il s'est toujours
dépassé et il a toujours résisté à
l'échec donc aujourd'hui moi je prends
en considération cette résistance à
l'échec cette faculté de rebondir cette
résilience lapierre lui ce
qu'il faut savoir prendre les personnes
dans leur tout avec leurs qualités leurs
défauts les défauts de leurs qualités
moi je retiens surtout de bernard tapie
le l'intensité de ses combats ses
combats durant sa vie ses combats
politiques ces combats sportifs et
évidemment son dernier combat aussi les
soirées combat contre la maladie est
évidemment quentin tout d'abord pour ma
génération pas tapisserie c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup marqué notre
génération finalement c'est quelqu'un de
15 années 80 90 et finalement pour nous
il n'a pas représenté forcément grand
chose aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il a
été écarté au fond de la politique
après les années 95 points
comme ses comptes disposant tout haut
aux européennes
soutenues et enfin par mitterrand pour
pour contrer la candidature de michel
rocard en réalité ça et c'est vrai
qu'après il a disparu de la politique et
je tiendrai quand même deux choses
importantes chez lui donc pareil en
écartant aussi tout les mauvais côtés de
monsieur tapie le bon côté de l' origine
populaire qui n'a jamais oublié de ce
lien avec avec la france la france du
banc pourrait dire est aussi un combat
extrêmement claires les positions
extrêmement clair contre le fn est
content extrême droite qui est un combat
qui reste admirable est important dans
une période et c'était oui une façon
d'ailleurs assez originale de lutter
contre l'extrême droite s'était pas sur
le plan moral nous faut ce qu'a fait
beaucoup la gauche c'était dans le même
combat il ya le débat le pen tapie
c'était un combat de make up presque
jean-charles jani
khel oui je viens de me joindre à ce
concert vous
oubliez la non nous on va pas un
hollandais disque et là parler du
personnage après ce qui m'amuse un peu
c'est quand on parle de ce combat contre
le front national
c'est un des combats qu'il a perdu enfin
je veux dire parce que très honnêtement
lui et mitterrand ils n'ont fait que
faire monter le front national donc
voilà je ne vois pas trop ce qu'on peut
il n'y a pas de gloire
tapie contre le front national non c'est
une sorte de d'artifice enfin je veux
dire ça faisait de l'audience s'était
très bien sa place à servir le président
mitterrand on regarde les chiffres avant
différents et après on regarde je suis
avant tapis et après le front national
n'a fait que grimper donc voilà je vis
dans là il a fait plein d'autres choses
très bien il a fait plein d'autres
choses moins bien mais mais qu'on arrête
de nous parler de cette lutte soit
disant contre le front national nommé au
pop on peut pas lui retirer que ça a été
une lutte constante et qu'il est même
menés sur le terrain dans les
bouches-du-rhône roule le front national
était et est très puissant et qu'il a
peut être réussi aussi à le faire
reculer dans ce département en tout cas
la série ron pardon
oui moi je me joins
me joins à toutes ces
louanges à tous ces reconnaissances qui
via à l'égard de bernard tapie j'en
rajouterai une peut-être avec un petit
peu de sarcasme mais mais c'est gentil à
l'égard de bernard tapie c'est que en
tant qu'enseignants et quand on enseigne
notamment le droit constitutionnel à des
étudiants de première année bernard
tapie nous a permis aussi de faire
évoluer d'enseignement il ne trouve une
illustration intéressante sur la
responsabilité pénale des ministres et
du chef de l'état notamment l affaire du
crédit lyonnais où il y avait des
imbrications entre christine lagarde
nicolas sarkozy et c est donc là dessus
c'est un crime assez sympathique de
pouvoir avoir une illustration mais je
retiens moi en tant que parce que c'est
aussi une question générationnelle le
duo qu'il a fait avec doc gynéco parce
que bernard tapie a été certes ministre
d'avis le dirigeant de l'om etc mais
aussi rappeur et ça il faut pas
l'oublier oui c'est vrai c'est peut-être
ça qui touche aussi c'était c'est ce que
disait si vous disiez tout à l'heure de
l'essonne c'est à dire cette
multiplicité d'activités cette
multiplicité de vie au fond et c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui touche un peu les
français et puis c'est vrai qu'on s'a
bac on sort on ne respecte toujours ce
combat comme vous disiez face à face à
la maladie qui était il s'est montré que
ça m'encourage je crois maintenant après
c'est vrai qu'il ya des c'est quelqu'un
qui a tout connu il a connu les
ministères et la prison il a connu la
réussite et les échecs enfin donc c'est
une vie à un probablement pour
romanesque aussi et c'est vrai que là
pour l'instant on est dans le dans les
loges absolue et vous avez raison jean
charles il ya peut-être aussi des côtés
plus son groupe lui on brasse vue sur
laquelle on pourra revenir m peut-être
un peu plus tard sur là-dessus voulait
ajouter quelque chose bien non c'est pas
la peine alors on va passer peut-être au
premier sujet on va aborder la politique
dans quelques instants mais il ya un
livre intéressant
de jérôme fourquet et de jean-laurent
cassely qui s'appelle la france sous nos
yeux qui dresse un portrait de la france
d'aujourd'hui et on va en parler
quelques instants suns donc quel est ce
nouveau paysage français
[Musique]
donc ce livre s'appelle la france sous
nos yeux dit au seuil
on peut remarquer plusieurs plusieurs
phénomènes
le premier c'est peut-être le passage
d'une économie de production une
économie de consommation et il ya un
chiffrement qui m'a frappé il y avait en
1981 je crois
181 330 par dont 310 intermarché il y en
a 10 830 aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce
paysage rythmée par les grandes surfaces
ça a beaucoup changé non pierre ça
évolue beaucoup évolué et évidemment ça
avait déjà évolué dès les années 60
niveaux mais hypermarchés la question
qui se pose c'est où d'où vient cette
cette consommation enfin d'où vient le
produit de cette consommation
où sont fabriqués nos biens du quotidien
nos voitures nous matériaux de
construction on en parle assez peu en
terme de consommation mais ça représente
une part importante la consommation
s'est tous les matériaux de construction
toutes ces choses là dont on dépend
maintenant à plus d'un titre la vraie
question c'est d'où vient-il qui sort du
lot des grandes surfaces dans des petits
commerces sur internet principalement
aussi maintenant et comme il dit
l'important c'est qu'il soit vendu en
france par des sociétés qui payent leurs
impôts en france et
l'idéal ce serait qu'ils soient plus
produit enfants plus tôt des enfants et
c'est vrai que le thème le de la
relocalisation
va être un thème important derrière des
des présidentielles probablement had la
robe production française de relancer la
production française de consommer plus
proche de chez nous des produits si
possible fabriqué en france c'est vrai
que ça va être un des thèmes de la de la
présidentielle c'est un des thèmes
centraux du plan de relance lancé par le
gouvernement l'an dernier et qui déjà
porte ses fruits puisque n'importe où en
france dès des emplacements tout prêt
pour recevoir des usines des lieux de
production ont déjà été
préparer et les premiers dossiers ont
été acceptés les points de vie commence
à se réinstaller en france parfois des
endroits qui ont été sérieusement
touchées par les différentes crises
économiques et les délocalisations par
le passé dans le passé sur ce portrait
comme ça de la france quant à des mères
comment vous la voyez la france l'a
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que vous vous êtes par
exemple engagé au parti gaulliste
la tradition du parti gaulliste c'est
d'être fondée sur la lutte des classes
on a l'impression que cette lutte des
classes est en train d'évoluer justement
il ya une des grandes coupures que
relève fourquet et son coauteur cassely
c'est la coupure entre la france urbaine
est ce qu'on appelle la france péri
urbaines périphériques je parlais
d'aider des supermarchés c'est la fin en
soi peu des supermarchés
cette cette logique de la lutte des
classes vous la voyez quand même
toujours présente où on admet tout à
fait qu'il ya plusieurs fractures dans
le pays et qui a pas forcément que la
lutte des classes mais pour autant oui
il ya une lutte des classes qui
continuent
alors c'est sûr qu'elle est moins
visibles qu'avant à une époque où tout
le monde était habillé en bleu pour la
lysine par exemple ou la maison du
patron était en face de lusine c'est
très clair de voir la lutte des classes
où il était aujourd'hui on est dans un
monde qui est très mondialisé où les
entreprises appartiennent à des groupes
internationaux on ne voit plus son
patron ne sait plus qui dirige son
patron et même son patron le pdg devenu
un salarié un peu comme les autres
finalement qui est dirigé par les
actionnaires et donc au final je vais
voir voir un peu et c'est vrai et donc
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a divisé
le monde du travail et qui fait qu'avant
on avait une même entreprise mille
personnes travaillent au même endroit
maintenant ils sont tous divisés chacun
des petits endroits on a eu l'impression
du chômage avec donc une délocalisation
de beaucoup d'activités
donc elle est encore là cette lutte là
et on voit encore aujourd'hui
l'écrasante majorité des français
gagnent leur vie par leur travail et
qu'il ya toujours une minorité qui
gagnent beaucoup beaucoup sur le capital
et le capital continue à donner plus
d'argent que le travail et même à clé
les mesures du gouvernement à chaque
fois c'est toujours capital qui donne
plus que le travail on voit aujourd'hui
aussi avec notation des prix de
l'énergie on voit avec la crise sur sur
les salaires
cette lutte elle est encore là elle est
encore d'actualité et c'est pour ça que
oui je pense que il faut qu'on continue
permet à l'odyssée curseur la seule
lutte baisser c'est une coupure qui
existent encore et on rappelle juste
très rapidement sur le sur le partage
travail capital encore une fois dans les
années 80 on est à 70 30 % donc 70 % de
la richesse va au travail et 30% dans le
capital aujourd'hui on est plus vers 60
40 qu'on a perdu 10% du pib qui allait
avant à ceux qui travaillent et qui
maintenant on va à ceux qui qui profite
parce qu'ils sont payés terre est donc
là il ya un vrai enjeu pour moi de
redistribuer ça m comme dit certain à
sécher le capital pour pour que ceux qui
travaillent qui qu'issus de leur front
puisse vivre bien et dignement salomé
très lu sur cette france d'aujourd'hui
que dans laquelle vous vivez après tout
je suis d'accord sur le fait qu'il ya
une mutation de l'économie en général et
nos façons consommer nos façons produire
il ya aussi une mutation des classes
sociales et on voit que la crise
sanitaire a vraiment relancé tous les
débats autour de la france future quoi
faire avec cette france voit que ça a
vraiment galvanisé d'un côté les classes
moyennes et de l'autre les classes
plutôt aisés donc à voir ce que les
futurs candidats à la présidentielle
vont proposer justement pour renouveler
et la france économique et la france
social j'ai l'impression qu'on oublie
peut-être un peu les classes les plus
défavorisées peut-être oui notamment et
pendant cette crise sanitaire enfin
c'est mon point de vue gênant
spécialement à étudier la question mais
je me sens que les pauvres sont plus
pauvres qu'avant encore nelson veigas
pas alors j'ai entendu parler du plan de
relance ça ça me fait beaucoup rire
personnellement parce que le plan de
relance alors par l'union européenne ne
serait pas bien guéri après
thierry après un plan de relance mais
lorsqu'on donne pratiquement 80
milliards d'euros à l'union européenne
on reçoit à peine 40 dont les dépenses
sont conditionnés à certains secteurs
j'ai plus observer personnellement
pendant la crise co-lead des petits
restaurants de petits propriétaires qui
fermait et des grands groupes qui
rachetaient ces emplacements parce que
les emplacements coûter moins cher parce
qu'on était en pleine crise économique
c'est plutôt le phénomène que j'ai
observé et justement les intermarchés
sont sont très révélateurs de tout ça en
pet qui se passe c'est que toutes les
tous les petits propriétaires tous les
petits chefs d'entreprises se font petit
à petit racheté par le grand capital qui
se développe donc moins de localisme
moins d'impôts payés en france également
pour certaines plates formes en ligne ou
pour certaines entreprises certains gars
femme est moins de l'organisme donc
moins de produits français consommer
donc les agriculteurs français en grande
difficulté donc on va citer cet exemple
un agriculteur sur deux qui gagnent
moins de 400 euros par mois en france
aujourd'hui et si vous êtes vous êtes
membre de l air 1 je suis membre de l
air j'ai ma carte en tout cas reçu un
avis qui est un monde de l air qui parle
du grand capital ça faisait longtemps
vincent peut-être peut-être de réponse
sur le sur l'europe et le plan de
relance européen pour remettre les
choses au point
oui moi je suis toujours assez étonné
que en soi comment dire on fasse aussi
rapidement des calculs sur ce que la
france donne à l'union européenne et ce
qu'elle reçoit en subventions en réalité
c'est pas du tout comme ça que il faut
calculer en fait le ce que la france
donne ou reçoit de l'union européenne la
france verse effectivement au budget
union européenne plus que ce qu'elle
reçoit en subventions mais combien la
france reçoit tel chaque année grâce à
son appartenance au marché intérieur
croissance qui est générée grâce à grâce
à tout cela et c'est très bien calculé
aujourd'hui on considère que c'est à peu
près 4 5 fois plus que ce qu'elle donne
un budget l'union européenne donc je
pense qu'il faut pas faire un calcul
purement budgétaire là dessus il ya
aussi un calcul économique beaucoup plus
large
je vous interromps une seconde mais
faudra peut-être show considérer que
l'europe c'est aussi une solidarité
entre les pays qui la composent
oui ben disons que là on le voit très
bien pour la crise sanitaire sur ce plan
de relance il n'aurait pas pu être fait
si son remboursement ne reposait pas sur
l'impôt c'est-à-dire que ces 750
milliards d'euros que l'on a que l'union
européenne va afin est en train
d'emprunter la france avait déjà reçu
cinq milliards iront se trouvera un
nouveau 5 milliards dans quelques jours
qui recevra au total 40 milliards
et bien tout ça va être remboursée par
un impôt européen qui sera payée
essentiellement par les entreprises non
européennes qui importe dans l'union
européenne des produits qui ne
respectent pas nos normes
environnementales sociales etc donc
c'est ça en fait aussi c'est cette
solidarité européenne qui fait qu'on
arrive à à redistribuer cet argent sur
l'ensemble du territoire et que serait
en fait la richesse de la france s'il y
avait eu une italie qui était au bord de
la faillite ou une pologne pauvre géré
c'est ça aussi la solidarité européenne
voilà je pense que c'était important de
répondre à ce que ce que vous disiez
jean charles lajoie dit peut-être sur
cette france alors c'est vrai que la
force des idées jaune quoi enfin qui
était la france de la périphérie qu'on a
vu s'exprimer pendant toutes ces
manifestations à ces mouvements qui est
assez structurantes et si on regarde au
fond aussi on suit un peu ce que disent
fourques et cassidy entre cette france
urbaine et cette france périphérique on
a un peu la coupure macron le pen qui
comme assez structurantes
oui c'est peut-être un peu réducteur
comme comme analyse et puis je pense
qu'il serait quand même temps de
d'arrêter de toujours parler du front
national et de et de le pen comme une
sorte de marqueurs qui seraient les
vannes qui couperait la france en deux
heureusement la france n'est pas coupée
en 2 55 ans et 50% pour le prendrais
siona donc donc il faut arrêter on peut
être gilet jaune et avoir d'autres
sensibilités politiques le front
national subit pas du tout une passion
pour les jd jaune vous me connaissez
mais de là tout est traité de suppôt du
front national serait probablement
exagéré non parce que
comment c'est parce qu'elle est dit
jeudi que cette coupure a l'air assez
structurantes oui toi de france quand
même il ya bien évidemment une coupure
mais
franchement je dirais plus puisqu'on
parle un petit peu d gilet jaune est ce
qu'il n'est pas plus agréable de vivre
un peu à l'écart d'une grande ville dans
un pavillon qu'ils ont eux mêmes choisie
entouré d'un petit jardinet que
l'habileté dans une cité à problèmes
alors voilà
on peut pas toujours se plaindre la
majorité des gens ont quand même choisi
peut-être d'exil et après ils
s'aperçoivent que bah oui il est censé
gérer donc voilà c'est face à mais
pourquoi je dis ça parce que je reviens
à votre question du début sur cette
france de bourg et supermarchés etc et
là il ya aussi je vous allez dire au
delà de toute la politique une
recherche du consommateur qui devrait un
petit peu faire attention avant de
perpétuellement râler contre tous je
veux dire les petits commerces existent
ils ont fait beaucoup d'efforts on peut
y aller les choses fabriquées en france
on peut les acheter c'est un de nos plus
cher mais on peut en acheter un petit
peu moins etc on peut consommer
raisonnablement et de temps en temps à
consommer français et puis enfin et je
termine juste là dessus il faut arrêter
cette espèce de noeud de niaiseries
permanente qui consistera à dire il faut
tout retour localisée mais il ya des
choses qu'on ne sait pas faire qu'on ne
saura pas faire et tant mieux on sait
faire des sous marins on a un petit peu
de mal à les vendre mais faisons ça les
masses on sait pas les faire et quand on
les fait en effet trop cher donc
laissons tomber les masques quelques les
tunisiens et des chinois passent des
masses ils les font à bas coûts et on en
profite c'est idiot de se battre là
dessus dire battons nous sur ce qu'on
sait faire et arrêtons de vouloir
s'isoler comme tels que comme des fous
il est aussi très bien que des pays
puisse vivre et que des pays puissent
avoir du travail ça ne me choque pas du
tout après le consommateur de choisir et
voilà maintenant je pense qu autour de
la table on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont tous sûrement venu en basket
j'imagine que tout leur basket viennent
de chine voilà est-ce que là c'est on
est dans une certaine incertaine
illogisme de cette génération qui passe
d'un an à un peu de lait des leçons et
puis qui passe son temps connecté sur
les ordis les baskets de salomé ne
viennent pas de chine
ce ne sont pas des bailleurs sont pas
des baskets non plus
on avait répondu
la suède
arguments des années 60 qu'on entendait
et qui ont conduit à ce qui est plus
d'industrie en france aujourd'hui les
pays les plus pauvres comme la chine
produiront la petite production pendant
que nous on produira les grandes
technologies comment - des milliards
ensuite on voit ce que la chine deuxième
aujourd'hui on voit ce que la france
devient aujourd'hui également et
peut-être que c'est vrai qu'il ya des
secteurs sur lesquels on est on est
meilleurs de trôner - pour les russes
alors rapidement puisqu'on va passer
woods mais justement sur cette coupure
de là on dit beaucoup un que l rmc le
cde partie de la france urbaine partie
de ceux qui réussissent au fond ça c'est
l'interprétation que certains ont voulu
faire emmanuel macron puis 2016 portant
un progrès d'émancipation c'est un
projet qui vise à faire en sorte que
chacun puisse avoir la vie qui fait
qu'ils soient dans la ruralité qui sont
en ville et quand on travaille sur une
réforme des retraites qui permettraient
une répartition plus juste de des
retraites une une retraite minimale pour
les agriculteurs ont parlé des
agriculteurs tout à l'heure on peut on
peut
déplorer lors leur situation actuelle
mais on peut aussi faire en sorte
qu'elle s'améliore et c'est ce qu'on
fait depuis cinq ans pour améliorer le
site des leçons de tout le monde que ce
soit les personnes en ville les
personnes à la campagne quel que soit
leur profession on va pas sélectionner
untel ou untel et n'ont
cédé que cdpa mai mais c'est vrai que
peut-être qu'il ya une force qui se
reconnaît un peu plus dans un manuel
macro qui frotte un peu
probablement la france qui réussit c'est
que je partage votre point de vue parce
que ceux-ci ce qu'on essaye la petite
musique politique qu'on essaye de mettre
en place sous prétexte que manuel macron
est un énarque ancien banquier on a
voulu construire une image de
président dédié à la start up née mène
alors que factuellement quand on regarde
la politique qui a été menée depuis cinq
ans
oui la france urbaine en a bénéficié
mais
la france de la ruralité aussi vous y
prenez la taxe d'habitation la taxe
d'habitation est un impôt quand même
relativement justement réparti son
territoire est aujourd'hui 80% de la
population y compris la population est
rurale payent moins de taxes d'habitants
bay pluvieux pour 80% d'hommes quant à
nos passagers un peu étonné je rappelle
que le l'une des toutes premières
mesures pris par macron c'est la
suppression des ss qui n'aiment pas le
meilleur message envoyé on vienne depuis
le début du quinquennat la suppression
de services publics au niveau local des
postes qui ferment et dénis
effectivement c'est faux la maison de
service public il ya 5000 qui ont été
ouvertes depuis 2017 c'est justement le
retour du service public quand on pleure
elle est brûlée à presse locale aux
parents avec le village de 150 habitants
ou en 2017 il n'y avait plus que la
mairie et y l'épicerie la mairie elle
fait poste elle fait
rouler le tout serait le service public
c'est même pas vraiment une maison de
nuit en france ça vis encore mais une
maison france services couverts à
proximité
on a réouvert cinq milieux d'accueil
pour lui c'est pas des lieux où il ya
une borne numérique où on laisse les
gens se débrouiller alors qu'ils savent
pas forcément s'en servir parce que tout
le monde n'est pas à l'aise avec ça
c'est un lieu dans lequel il être humain
vote qui accueille les personnes qui
jusqu'à maintenant de faire 10 15 20 25
km pour accéder à des services publics
qu'on me dise pas qu'ils les abandonnent
postes supprimés dans la presse j'ai lu
il ya pas si longtemps ils valent de
plusieurs milliers de postes supprimés
depuis début du quinquennat dans
l'éducation nationale
là combien de lits supprimé on parle
aussi a eu encore un scandale jeudi par
le monde de 10 supprimé il ya quand même
et quand même des messages qui sont
envoyées moi j'entends le discours en
tant que discours même mais quand on va
dans les territoires à petit les
territoires qui sont plus épargnés que
d'autre part étaient aléatoires moi je
vois aussi je contacte avec beaucoup
d'élus qui me disent combien doivent se
battre pour garder leur poste pour
garder leur chose alors on essaye de
rassembler comme on peut pour sauver les
meubles avec un tabac qui va faire la
poste et autres c'est pas forcément la
meilleure solution et ça montre en fait
un seul message c'est que bâle et à
finalement se désengage les territoires
il laisse moi les territoires après on
pas s'étonner que des gens qui ont
acheté un pavillon c'est vrai parce que
s'il y avait la france des propriétaires
il y avait le seul moyen de des
propriétaires s'étaient acheté loin et
bah en même temps leur ferme tout après
ils sont bien d'avoir leur voiture on
leur tape dessus sur le milieu car c'est
ce qui a provoqué le mouvement des jeux
c'est quand même l'impression d'être un
mot donné d'être un petit peu vu huy
d'avoir fait des mauvais choix mais qui
est elle s'était par l'état à l'époque
alors voulait répondre non enfin
parler des délits l'hôpital l'ailier
l'hôtel c'est le contre exemple parfait
une grande partie des lieux de soins qui
ferme le font par manque de personnel
médical pour ces versets lice à rien
d'avoir dix mille lits si vous n'avez
pas de médecins continuent les personnes
qui sont devant et ça c'est l'exemple
parfait du résultat de dizaines d'années
de politique de santé qui n'a pas permis
d'avoir suffisamment de médecins
d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants pour
soigner les grands oui à un moment il
faut fermer des lignes si vous n'avez
pas de médecin simplement donc qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que le gouvernement qu'est ce
qui amène le mec en effet dès le début
de son quinquennat il a débloqué les
verrous qui vont permettre mais
forcément c'est assez vous d'avoir plus
de médecins et donc qui permettront
d'avoir des lieux aussi à la des
meilleurs endroits où la population
s'est déplacée on n'a pas du tout la
même répartition la population sur le
territoire pouvait pas avoir conduit les
mêmes répartition des lits au même
endroit c'est comme pour les écoles le
nombre d'élèves à l'école grosso modo à
diminuer et diminue donc le on peut pas
garder autant d'écoles que qu'est-ce
qu'on pouvait avoir auparavant alors le
problème c'était cette lourde efforts
sur un effet de taille notamment dans
les villages que vous avez deux trois
classes ben vous avez trois classes le
nombre d'élèves diminue quand vous allez
supprimer une classe ouverte rurales et
des classes surpeuplées et donc là après
c'est du cas par cas c'est
problématique par télématique on regarde
c'est pour ça des fois il ya des classes
qui qui se mobilisent les écoles qui se
mobilisent contre la fermeture d'une
classe et ça peut attirer l'attention au
service de l'éducation nationale de
mieux faire attention
à cet emplacement de regarder de faire
du cas par cas on peut pas faire une
politique globale on peut pas dire allez
on augmente de 10% nombre de classes
sans se poser la question d'où on
l'aimait et qu'elle élève en mai de l'an
on va pas de même une question qui n'est
jamais si tu essaies de la rémunération
des agents le collège à côté de chez moi
par exemple différents profs qui manque
et je pense que s'il manque c'est
notamment dû à des rémunérations trop
faible qui fait que ça n'incite pas les
gens qui ont augmenté dans le paquet
mais pas forcément assez pour rattraper
voici mox et audi a6 mon
travail ici manque des infirmières six
épreuves retrouve ses métiers notamment
la question des débuts difficiles aussi
des initiales repart et alors on va
passer à la politique on avait commencé
à en parler et on va commencer avec la
condamnation évidemment d'un ancien
président de la république de nicolas
sarkozy
[Musique]
alors donc nicolas sarkozy a été
condamné à un an de prison pour
financement illégal de sa campagne
électorale de 2012 il fait appel de
cette décision ne connaît pas applicable
vincent couronne
alors après on m'a dit c'est une c'est
trop s'est passé peu importe mais c'est
vrai que c'est plus ce que c'était des
réquisitions et c'est la peine maximale
oui dans cette affaire comment dire et
de manière générale en matière pénale le
juge a tout à fait la possibilité
d'aller au delà des réquisitions du
parquet c'est ce qu'il a fait ici en
l'espèce dans cette affaire pour une
raison simple
c'est le fait que et comme le précise le
jugement de ce qu en tout cas on en a lu
dans la dans la presse c'est que nicolas
sarkozy
n'était pas un novice en politique et
que donc ils savent exactement comment
fonctionner le financement d'une
campagne électorale et qu' ils savaient
très bien parce qu'il avait été alerté à
plusieurs reprises
quels étaient les risques encourus tant
que c'est cela qu'a voulu souligné le
tribunal maintenant nicolas sarkozy se
défend en disant qu' il a été condamné
deux fois pour les mêmes faits et que
c'est contraire aux principes du droit
pénal et c'est parce qu'il avait déjà
été effectivement il a déjà eu subi une
sanction de la commission nationale des
comptes de campagne qui l'avait
sanctionné leur nom comment dire à peu
près pour les pas exactement pour les
mêmes faits mais dans la même affaire en
tout cas sauf que en fait ce sont deux
sanctions qui n'ont pas le même objectif
la première sanction c'est une sanction
administrative qui a pour but de
s'assurer du bon déroulement de la
campagne il avait été condamné pour le
dépassement du plafond est hélas ici
cette sanction c'est une sanction pénale
pour réprimer
une violation de la loi notamment sur le
sur le système de financement de sa
campagne et d'ailleurs ils disent à un
nicolas sarkozy se plaint de ces deux
sanctions alors que c'est lui même qui
avait saisi le conseil constitutionnel
en 2019 et que c'est à cette occasion
que le conseil constitutionnel avait dit
a pas de problème de double peine en
quelque sorte dans cette affaire
donc là on est dans une application très
classique du droit pénal et
sansan des mesures ni rien en réalité ce
qui est nouveau ici c'est la
condamnation d'un chef d'un ancien chef
d'état pour ce motif qui pour le coup
une première oui quand il dit c'est
contraire à la décision du conseil
constitutionnel vous dites non au
contraire cette décision
les
sept condamnations c'est pas la première
fois qu'un président de la république
l'ancien président de la république et
coordonnée jacques chirac l'avait été un
an ferme c'est là c'est quand même la
première fois
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes
l air donc vous avez l'impression qu'il
ya un acharnement des juges alors sur la
question est ce qu'il ya une justice
politique ou non je pense que c'est pas
sur cette affaire qu'on va pouvoir
illustrer cet exemple en tout cas pas au
mieux sa plus saturés d'affaires fillon
il ya tout un calendrier judiciaire qui
est bouleversée du jour au lendemain en
pleine élection présidentielle où tous
les médias mainstream commence à vous
mettre 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
une image du candidat accusés comme
s'ils étaient déjà condamnés
ça c'est plus un acharnement politique
et médiatique et judiciaire parce qu'on
entend beaucoup chez les sarkozystes
des juges contre l'ancien président de
la république mais je vais répondre
c'est que si un homme politique quel
qu'il soit que ce soit nicolas sarkozy
ou un autre finances de manière illégale
sa campagne il doit être condamné comme
n'importe qui qui financerait 5 en panne
inégalement ou comme serai un chef
d'entreprise qui ait recours à des
financements illégaux devraient être
condamnés également la question c'est
pourquoi des aménagements de peine par
exemple en résidence surveillée ou autre
si si un condamné pour le même fait
croire que sarkozy ne n'aurais pas ces
aménagements la justice est la même pour
tous il n'ya pas avoir d'aménagement ni
de désavantage de handicap sur une
condamnation cc on applique la loi tient
plus sur cette condamnation je pas
l'habitude de commenter à l'est
notamment en matière pénale c'est totale
confiance en lice pour prendre les
bonnes décisions y compris les décisions
d'aménagement de peine c'est ça fait
partie intégrante de la décision de
justice moi je soulignerai juste là peu
les mines hypocrisie d'une partie d'une
grande partie de la droite qui
pour beaucoup on a vu plusieurs reprises
des extraits où il demandait la fin des
aménagements de peine
voilà on va regarder on va regarder
justement nicolas sarkozy et xavier
bertrand nicolas sarkozy d'abord une
peine prononcée doit être une peine
exécutée et par conséquent toute peine
supérieure à 6 mois sera intégralement
exécuté voilà la politique pénale que
nous proposons et xavier bertrand aussi
il était un petit refrain toute personne
condamnée à une peine même légère doi
l'effectuer rapidement ça semble être
une évidence et pourtant
voilà c'est vrai que il ya deux discours
il ya en effet un discours un peu pour
les autres et un disque au bon pour soi
même nous y voyons une contradiction
quant à m bah moi je suis content de
voir qu'une justice dans un pays
démocratique peut condamner un ancien
président de la république pour des
faits de délinquance une politique mais
qui sont graves on pas quand même 2
millions dans cette histoire là donc moi
je peux être que très content de voir ça
et je suis d'accord avec cette question
d' hypocrisie d'une partie de la classe
politique
ça ne lui fera pas forcément de mal
d'aller en prison et ça peut rassurer
les français de se dire que le personnel
politique est bien proche d'eux et que
quand il faut t'il peuvent aller à la
prison n'y a pas d'impunité même pour un
président de la république alors après
la prison sera peut-être pas de la
prison ça peut ça peut être aussi une
forme d'exécution de la peine qui est un
peu différent salomé trélut alors je
peux comprendre que nicolas sarkozy soit
déçu par par cette peine au vu de la la
la durée
après pour moi les preuves sont vraiment
irréfutables et je fais confiance à la
justice pénale est d'accord monde et son
hypocrisie parce qu'en plus selon un
responsable en marge juste à côté on
peut noter exactement sous une forme
différente les mêmes procédés sous la
compagne d'emmanuelle macron il ya eu
des salles de meeting à moins 30 moins
50 parfois même à moi 100 % du tarif
pratique et donc il ya eu enfin enfin il
ya eu une grosse différence c'est que
telle enquête dans notre cas n'a pas la
commission des comptes de campagne il va
mourir aucun problème ont déjà rappelé
que les comptes de nicolas sarkozy avait
été cesser avait été
démontré à plusieurs reprises j'ai eu un
haut rendement des personnes non
visibles qu'on fait des pressions sur
leurs compères qui détenaient des salles
pour les aciéries les ont eu beaucoup
moins cher que les autres candidats
comme si c'était une association
cependant c'était un parti politique en
campagne qui était financé pour plus de
la moitié de son budget de campagne par
chèque de 7500 euros les pires lui c'est
raisonnable et qu'il y avait jamais vu
mais c'est mon voisin qui me l'a dit il
ya des enquêtes journalistiques 1 il
suffit d'aller lire marianne il suffit
d'aller dire le monde il ya désormais en
voie de condamnation non il n'y a pas de
condamnation
n'a sûrement pas de condamnation d'un
président en exercice qui bénéficie
d'une dix minutes et
pour les contacts pour ce qu'il fait
quand il est président et fort matière
pénale sexy demain et tue quelqu'un ou
ivan région
aujourd'hui tant qu'il est président il
ne peut pas être condamné jean charles
lajoie zee sur la condamner sur deux de
nicosie est ce qu'elle va faire devant
des juges à votre avis j'ai pas entendu
votre question est ce qu'est un
acharnement dg jeu contre nicolas
sarkozy
je pense que c'est au delà de
l'acharnement ça relève de la vengeance
on sait très bien que nicolas sarkozy
avait manqué de la plus élémentaire
prudence en s'attaquant aux juges dans
les traitant de petit pois ils n'ont
jamais pardonné on se souvient en plus
de la magistrature enfin du du bureau
avec le mur des cons enfin on se
souvient de tout ça il est évident que
lorsque je m'étonne que vincent couronne
trouve ça normal d'aller au delà des
réquisitions et que la peine soit la
plus lourde et qui parle d'une justice
tout à fait sereine ont ce qu'on sait
très bien que les fenêtres des juges
sont payés l'ancien président alors on
discute peut-être pas une décision de
justice d'avoir une copine et il a fait
appel donc il n'est pas condamné mais
c'est quand même à l'évidence un
acharnement
les juges essaye de s'arranger un
pouvoir au delà des politiques bon ça
leur fait plaisir je ne vois pas en quoi
la démocratie ressortent gagnants de sa
première chose mais l'autre réflexion
plus notre réflexion que ça m'inspire
c'est
ce qui m'épate un peu c'est ce
déchaînement de haine mais même autour
de ce plateau on a l'impression que les
gens sont presque orgasmique parce que
nicolas sarkozy cristallise je ne serai
pas pourquoi cette cette volonté alors
que quand bernard tapie et condamné on
trouve ça très bien on lit ces
merveilleux et puis là on dire non mais
ça fait on va quand même pas couper la
tête de nicolas sarkozy il faut pour
arrêter ce déchaînement de haine a été
inexplicable inexplicable
va savoir je passais un autre notre
question c'est on entend quand même et
il ya des propositions dans cette
campagne électorale
une crainte de l'arrivée d'une
république des juges et il ya des
propositions pour réduire les pouvoirs
du conseil constitutionnel ou de la cour
de justice européenne
sur le fond alors je veux pas vous
demander précisément sur telle ou telle
proposition mais sur le fond est ce que
vous craignez vous qui êtes dur et c'est
une république des juges
la notion de degré public ou de
gouvernement des juges c'est une c'est
une notion ancienne qui en réalité
remonte en france au début du 20e siècle
quand on observait la cour suprême
américaine commencé à défendre notamment
les droits civiques et c'est là que
beaucoup de français se sont inquiétés
de ce que les juges eux pouvaient sortir
de leur rôle en défendant les libertés
ou où les droits les droits fondamentaux
c'est de là que vient en fait la
question du risque de gouvernement des
juges aujourd'hui on ne conteste plus au
juge sa capacité à protéger les libertés
c'est même aujourd'hui devenue le pivot
de ses libertés et tout notre état de
droit c'est en fait construit autour de
ça c'est à dire que dans un système de
séparation des pouvoirs souvenez-vous
montesquieu qui disait il faut que enfin
tout homme qui a du pouvoir est porté à
en abuser il faut donc que par la
disposition des choses le pouvoir arrête
le pouvoir ils ont identifié trois
pouvoirs législatif exécutif et
judiciaire
aujourd'hui le législatif et l'exécutif
ont tellement avance tellement de
concerts tellement haut comment qu'il
n'ya plus vraiment de séparation entre
exécutif et législatif quel est le
dernier pouvoir qui reste en réalité
pour éviter l'arbitraire éviter un la
toute puissance de l'exécutif du
législatif
c'est le juge donc avant en fait de
réfléchir a selon moi en tout cas à
raboter les pouvoirs du juge peut-être
faudrait-il remettre un peu de
séparation entre l'exécutif et le
législatif
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que pourquoi pas raboter les
pouvoirs du juge pourquoi pas dire au
juge vous n'intervenez pas dans le
politique à un niveau présidentiel et
c'est ce qui est déjà un petit peu le
cas avec l'immunité
du président une par une une
irresponsabilité pénale partielle du
président mais souvenons nous de toutes
ces affaires qui ont émaillé la 3ème
4ème et même la cinquième république des
affaires criminelles parfois et qui
n'ont jamais pu être jugé parce que
justement les juges n'avaient pas ce
pouvoir là peut-on revenir au crime
crapuleux politique que l'on avait connu
jusqu aux années 80 voire même voire
même 90 je suis assure que la démocratie
en grandir et quand a accusé les juges
de trop s'immiscer dans le pouvoir
politique et d'en faire des affaires
personnelles en réalité pour peut-être
demander aux politiques d'être plus
exemplaire que ça au moins les juges ne
s'intéresse pas à eux c'est peut-être la
solution
c'est vrai que cette suite c'est une
bonne solution mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être une justice hors jeu j'emploie
des mots tels qu'ils sont mais justice
du monde actuel de les nouveaux mondes
qu'il vise aussi des pratiques de
l'ancien monde si vous avez raison de
rappeler que voilà il ya eu une période
où il y avait eu aucun contrôle où tout
était possible et où personne n'essaye
et de contrôler les comptes de campagne
c'est vrai que même le financement des
partis politiques c'était une longue
longue lutte pour la pole à réglementer
peut-être passé au deuxième sujet de la
politique c'est le casse-tête zemmour on
voit des sondages le donnent comme en
tête des candidats de droite devant
xavier bertrand devant valérie pécresse
qui s'était valérie pécresse
devant barnier s'était barnier est juste
est à l'eau de marine le pen c'est ce
qui fait que si on ajoute d'ailleurs
marine le pen et eric zemmour ils sont
10 en hausse et une droite extrême ça
fait 31 % quand même d'aider des
français qu'ils voteraient pour ce
conglomérat de droite droite forte en
tout cas ça vous inquiète pas
merlus déjà je pense que l'algorithmique
zemmour plus le pen c'est se méprendre
sur les électorats claquin je suis pas
certain que l'électorat de marine le pen
sur fans d'eric zemmour son intégralité
et inversement
c'est quand même mieux
quand on compte en lice que
proposez-vous c'est quand même une
droite très affirmée à c'est une droite
très affirmés ces mêmes de l'extrême
droite
je peux le dire sans problème et on
revient que zemmour prend aussi
l'électorat de la droite plus
traditionnelle
procès on est calme ce sondage on est à
six mois d'élections criant qu'il peut
se passer ça peut être une bulle qui
peut éclairer il m'inquiète pas plus que
n'importe quel autre candidat qui à
l'heure actuelle en tout cas avec avec
les autres comme la droite se bagarrent
pour au final pour être le candidat de
la droite puisque on voit à quel point
une partie aussi des fédérations à l'air
s'acoquine avec eric zemmour l'accueille
comme ce talent il froisse week end
étaient accueillis à bras ouverts
permanence l heure locale
ces moelleux
on se bat depuis que la politique depuis
2016 eric zemmour représente à peu près
tout ce contre quoi je vous les algues
bayer pourquoi je me suis engagé en
politique c'est une personne qui qui
joue avec les vérités qui ment qui fait
passer ses discours pour des discours de
prof d'histoire alors que il s'excuse
dans vos billets tout le monde racontant
n'importe quoi et
ça s'entend ces propos sont racistes
il va manifester avec la droite
homophobes
hongrie enfin c'est c'est absolument pas
de but c'est pas du tout 2021 quoi c'est
à la rigueur c'est c'est 1921 mais mais
c'est pas long mais on entend bien ce
discours mais quand même il est
aujourd'hui à 15% alors ils sont ce
qu'ils sont et vous avez raison de
rappeler qu'on est encore à six mois des
présidentielles et que que tout peut
évoluer mais il est quand même le
symptôme de quelque chose
le symptôme d'une d'une droite qui a
lentement dérivé vers l'extrême droite
depuis depuis des années et qui les
frappe maintenant aux as l'air parce que
oui faisons jongler et de gens qui se
disent est une partie importante
peut-être des français qui se disent on
ne reconnaît plus le pays dans lequel on
vit c'est peut-être
personne alors je suis content de savoir
qu'il ne vous fait pas peur en tout cas
il fait peur à vos supérieurs c'est déjà
une bonne nouvelle
alors eric zemmour il se définit pas
comme un prof d'histoire ça c'est encore
une contre-vérité exercice
il réaffirme à chaque fois qu'il n'est
pas historien eric zemmour avait dit
qu'il adore l'histoire qui est que tous
et tout son discours est fondé sur
l'histoire sur une vision de l'histoire
de france oui une barre il a vu rien il
a une vision de l'histoire défense assez
ce qui revendique c'est qu'il a une
vision de l'histoire de france ensuite
eric zemmour alors le mot extrême droite
a été lâchée j'aime bien qu'on sache ce
qu'on entend par l'extrême droite ça ça
m'intéresse beaucoup de savoir quelles
sont les conditions pour être d'extrême
droite et comment on est rangé dans ces
conditions là et de quelle manière ils
les remplit alors on a entendu encore
quelque chose d'assez impressionnant
pour un parti extrêmement propre pays
cet été des réalistes européens tels
qu'en marche sur la visite d'eric
zemmour en hongrie alors il faut savoir
que la hongrie elle doit toucher des
crédits européens
mais vu qu'elle souhaite organiser un
référendum sur la question des
interventions des personnes qui quittent
et construisent le genre est qui et qui
met dès l'école primaire la cause lgbt à
l'école eh ben ça
angry subi des chantages aux crédits
européens de cette manière là et clément
bonne qui est secrétaire d'état en
charge des affaires européennes sous le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron se
réjouit de cela est dit que l'union
européenne doit combattre les idées
reçues c'est pas bien que l'europe est
une certaine vision de la société
très fier que l'union européenne qui est
l'analyse numérique entre états elle a
bien le droit d'avoir une vision de ce
qu'elle de ce que peut être la société
parce que peuvent être les droits des
uns et des autres mais là l'europe non
là on ne sert pas les liens entre et là
on n'est pas dans l'europe pour faire ce
qu'on veut n'importe quoi du chantage
aux crédits européens sur des questions
idéologiques dans les pays ce n'est pas
vrai ça mais bien comme une action s'est
resserré les liens des chaînes à une
instit jeu sur couronne doivent oeuvrer
pour dessus mais b peut-être qu'un
travail jeudi commentaire sur ce qui
vient d'être dit je suis pas forcé suite
est assez critique sur l'union
européenne mais autant sur des valeurs
fondamentales on peut quand même pas
négocier sur d'autres choses
oui mais on parle aussi de gros groupes
homophobes et qui déteste les gbt équipe
ans équivaut à nîmes était partout qui
pensent qu'on va transformer les enfants
comme s'ils ont deux comme s'ils ont
transformé les enfants en gay ou une
lesbienne on est gay on l asie vient
donc trouvé trouvé que des enfants
puissent quand il découvre la sensualité
se rendre compte que c'est normal qu'ils
ont droit de vivre comme ils sont et
qu'en fait c'est la nature c'est quand
même mieux que dans une société dans une
vieille tradition catholique qui très
réactionnaire il faut le dire est
d'empêcher des gens de vivre heureux
comme ils sont on parle d'un changement
de genre avec des enfances assénant
primaire d'accès avec des hormones qui
détruisent leur santé mais à part ça
tout va bien au final on poser la
question de comment on dit exim ou
d'extrême-droite france seul le
meilleure définition les données par ses
propres partisans oui à je ne suis pas
partisan des régimes une contre-vérité
suite sallaumines comment vous expliquer
ce phénomène là justement si c'était
domaine et lyon
eric zemmour il dessinait un clivage
français qui est particulièrement
intéressant essayer de comprendre il
étaye plein de propos différents n ait
du mal vraiment à comprendre le fond de
sa pensée dire qu'il est d'extrême
droite mais on a du mal à comprendre
réellement ses propositions pour la
france et leurs fondements mais pour moi
aussi au sens comprend assez c'est quand
même c'est quand même vision un peu
nostalgique d'une société qui aurait été
13 unis il ya quelques années alors
c'est sans doute le mythe un mythe
français 1 qui développe une f1 voilà
c'est ça son eau sans son idée c'est que
il ya eu voilà une immigration qui est
arrivé qui ce qui s'assimile et
aujourd'hui cette assimilation des plus
possible et l'idée oui favorable à la
simulation est si difficile et si les
immigrés n'arrive pas ça se vit débat il
voulait renvoyer ce procès non c'est
assez simple à comprendre donc un peu de
projets sur le long terme pour la photo
sipa rapport au stade au statut de
l'état actuellement j'ai du mal à voir
comment son projet pour être compatible
avec l'état français sur le sur le court
terme
néanmoins on voit bien que eric zemmour
galvanise vraiment tout l'électorat
politique il il est il est au centre des
débats c'est ça qui il a réussi sept as
et farida votre nom oui pas de se
reproduire quant à moi je veux quand
même parler d'une un rôle important dans
les débats politiques c'est le rôle des
médias oui moi je comme assez étonné de
voir qu en fait dès que dès qu'il lève
la main dès qu'il fait quelque chose les
médias s'enchaînent moi j'ai on connaît
la situation aujourd'hui en france comme
le taux de pauvreté qu'on a en france la
difficulté qu'on a dans le monde du
travail et moi je peux tu vas avoir en
dehors de l'esprit l'impression qu'il ya
aussi une envie de détourner un petit
peu le débat des questions sociales sur
les questions identitaires pour
justement alimenter la droite et
l'extrême droite qui peut d'ailleurs
être favorable à monsieur macron puisque
du coup ça nous permet d'avoir un débat
très simple entre lui et l'extrême
droite il faut pas toucher donc oui je
pense qu'il serait un maquereau le pen
ont malheureusement je pense qu'il
serait content de se dire ah ben voilà
je redemande et aux gens de faire
barrage et je peux être quasiment sûre
d'être réélue et c'est quand même plus
facile sur facile d'être plus à gauche
que car le pen ou 15 amour donc moi j'ai
envie d'inviter les médias un petit peu
parler des vrais problèmes des gens de
parler des vrais soucis des questions de
salaires encore une fois des questions
des missions de travail les questions
des trésors du débat mais habile mais il
y est mis il y est mis par des personnes
il y est mis par des médias qui se
disent tiens ça c'est bien ça il fait
vendre des choses intéressent les gens
et alors il parle beaucoup il fait des
grandes polémiques mais fred un peu
mettre la raison dans les débats
politiques un peu plus de raison un peu
plus des vraies questions qui touchent
les gens et quand on parle avec les gens
directement c'est pas de ces pas
d'identité qui parle avant tout ils
parlent ils parlent de leur logement qui
est mal isolés ils parlent de leur
salaire qui est trop bas il parle de
ouais m'enfin vous avez quand même 15 %
pour l'oit au sérieux ce qui est quand
même énorme parce que quand on a une
collecte alors que les cardinals je suis
désolé mais oui
leader de votre parti est à combien mais
ça c'est un autre débat c'est un sondage
c'est moi la campagne n'est pas encore
fait mais encore il est à 2 vous êtes en
colère vous êtes en colère vous voyez
dans les médias où vous montre celui là
en comme étant celui qui incarne
l'alternative à mâcon vous vous dites ah
ben moi je suis énervé on me montre ce
gars là j'ai pas forcément le temps de
regarder le reste du
panorama politique qu'est ce que je fais
je vais voter pour lui en tout cas je
dis que je vais voter pour lui et c'est
aussi une machine qui s'entretient
elle-même avait au final jean charles
lajoie dit
écoutez je suis un peu je suis un peu
saisis parce que encore une fois c'est
toujours très facile de se débarasser
quelque chose avec cette étiquette
infamante idées d'extrême droite et puis
ça y est la messe est dite on passe à
orry pas de gauche quoi
il ya deux minutes enfin il ya quelques
minutes nous nous parlions d'une france
un peu un peu coupé en deux un peu la
france rurale de la france des villes
etc et je vois même notre ami du parti
communiste qui pense que on peut
résoudre le problème à tiques d'eric
zemmour en parlant de lgbt alors je suis
ravi que l'un d'entre eux cgt soit
quelque chose d'important mais si c'est
ça attaquer zemmour uniquement je pense
que la moitié les deux tiers de la
france se contrefiche pour l'instant de
la problématique lgbt non non c'est pas
dans c'est pas ça c'est son voyage c'est
s envoyer le serbe ana qui était oui
mais on essaie de la mairie n'était pas
le black et sodeval technique c'est pas
du tous cas plus important aie aie aie
ça me paraît tellement réducteur de bon
je vous dis encore une fois faisons une
émission à jour sur les gbt ce sera
passionnant mais c'est important non
pardon je suis désolé c'est important la
vision de l'europe que vous pouvez avoir
est ce que est ce que en effet on peut
laisser des gens comme urban dire ce
qu'ils veulent et rester dans l'europe
ou pas c'est quand même un débat
c'est ce qu'ils veulent mais cette mais
ce n'est pas le débat qui intéresse les
français les français pour l'instant
c'est parler c'est pas l'avenir de
l'élever bt et l'avenir de viktor orban
qui les intéressent et c'est ça c'est ça
le décroche sans sucre le soutien des
phalangistes importe quoi non mais après
après on s'étonne que zemmour face à
face 15% mais il fera peut-être 10 2% a
toujours dit nier les problèmes
c'est étape fut leur état à divorcer
c'est l'église il entraîne avec lui des
gens qui disent qu'ils se disent en
effet il ya des quartiers abandonnés de
la république c'est je crois que c'est
ça le fotso son électorat
que le pen ne peut plus gagner tout
simplement dès lors que je vois là et
que le pen les nuls et qui donne
raison vincent couronne
ou là y aurait je pense beaucoup pour
élire à l'affût de tout ce qui a été dit
oui 12e et gbt de faire le poids quand
même
[Rires]
mais c'est passionnant tous ces échanges
moi j'aime beaucoup vous voir échanger
et nous voir échanger tout sur ces
questions-là très diverses avec des
positions très très très très diverse
aussi très différente simplement en fait
je pense que ce qui fait notre comment
dire notre unité est ce qui fait le lien
entre nous tous c'est malgré tout notre
attachement à la démocratie notre
attachement aussi à l'état de droit et
la défense des libertés et c'est en ça
que
le rapprochement entre zemmour et et
viktor orban est quand même un sujet
d'actualité alors je m'inscris en faux
avec ce que dit jean charles sur le
sujet je pense c'est quand même un sujet
fondamental dans la politique
aujourd'hui parce que ça montre en fait
l'émergence en europe de ce qu'on
appelle lille libéralisme cher à viktor
orban et au gouvernement pour le dire en
tout cas la majorité actuelle en pologne
et un nouveau clivage en fait en europe
entre eux les progressistes ce qu'un
petit peu ce que macro 1 en quelque
sorte théorisé il ya déjà quelques
années et non pas des réactionnaires
mais ce qu'on appellerait des îles
libéraux c'est à dire des responsables
politiques qui est bien on voit en
marche arrière sur la question des
libertés pourquoi est ce qu'au niveau
européen c'est important parce que et
pourquoi est ce que l'europe peut
intervenir sur ces sujets là parce qu'en
2007 dans le traité de lisbonne tous les
états membres de l'union européenne à
l'unanimité ont inscrit un article dans
traité lisbonne article 7 du traité sont
européennes qui donne le pouvoir à
l'union européenne d'intervenir sur ces
sujets des valeurs de l'état de droit
des libertés le parlement européen qui
représente les citoyens de l'union
européenne et 450 millions citoyens de
l'union le parlement européen
démocratiquement élu en 2019 a rendu une
résolution qui l'adopté donc il y à il
ya quelques il ya quelques mois tout
juste
demandant à la commission européenne
d'intervenir en pologne et en hongrie
sur la question des libertés on a ici
donc nous double légitimité celle des
états et celle du peuple européen en
quelque sorte pour intervenir sur le
sujet des droits fondamentaux qu'on peut
pas dire vraiment après ça que l'union
européenne qui fait du chantage au
financement
en gris et bien et bien c'est toi sois
pas démocratique ou contraire à la
volonté des nations c'est complètement
faux ça va dans le sens de ce que
veulent les nations et ça va mon sens ce
que veulent les peuples européens et
enfin dernière dernière et après
j'arrête est-ce qu'on crie au chantage
de l'état lorsque contre des subventions
octroyées aux régions aux départements
aux communes il leur impose une
transition
énergétique il leur impose une politique
sociale et ainsi de suite jamais c'est
la même chose ici
merci de cette précision on va être on
arrive malheureusement à la fin de
l'émission je suis désolé parce que je
voulais qu'on parle de l air m et est de
7 ans on va en reparler on va redonner
aux gros
comme revenir sur cette coupure droite
gauche contre laquelle
emmanuel macron a
agi et contre laquelle il s'est fait il
y avait hier en 2017 est ce qu'elle est
toujours structurantes pour vous faire
de dire est-ce que c'est toujours
secteur de dire on est de droite et de
gauche
deux jours défilent 2016 tout le le tout
qu'il est justement de ne pas s'arrêter
à cette cette fissure c'est plus une
fracture en fait puisqu'on va très bien
que autant à gauche qu'à droite il ya
des vents contraires et qu'on peut très
bien et on l'a montré depuis cinq ans
proposer un projet politique
qui tient aussi bien des idées tradition
défendu par ego et d'autres
traditionnellement défendue par la
droite est sortie centrale allait elle
est le le principe même du centrisme
c'est d'admettre qui a une gauche et une
droite et
un tire le meilleur de chaque côté et
qu'on veut pour preuve que depuis depuis
cinq ans les gens de gauche ne traite de
vilains de droite et les gens de droite
nous traite de vie longue aux skis
utilisation
moi je pense pas honnêtement je ne pense
pas quand on défend la pma pour tout
c'est pas une droitisation du projet de
société quand on réduit l'impôt sur le
revenu quand on réduit la taxe
d'habitation quand on assiste la
transition écologique en finançant la
rénovation des bâtiments et les
bâtiments publics
petite gauche c'est le droit qui passe
pas je peux pas le dire en tout cas on
prendra je vous propose de revenir de
sincan dans une quinzaine de jours va on
va si vous êtes d'accord on va continuer
c'est ce débat c'était c'était patients
merci infiniment merci à tous et à très
vite alors la semaine prochaine deux
émissions spéciales sur la politique et
la religion et puis les débats sur
l'actualité dans une quinzaine de jours
merci à tous
[Musique]